hey guys we're back for another quick
episode of 10 things you missed where I
explored drangleic with you and as usual
let's make a game out of the like in the
dislike system if you learn something
new then you leave a like and if you
know everything then you win and you
leave a dislike if that happens this
inspires me to find some really good
facts so don't feel guilty about it
there is some really really weird stuff
down in the pit so decide if you're
going to play the game and let's get
started
we're going to work our way down the pit
naming things till we end up at the very
bottom the first thing that you probably
missed is hidden in the texture for the
corrosive acid in this pit before the
second bonfire that's right
a discarded Heineken beer ken is in this
trash texture and honestly it's not that
surprising that you missed this because
you know who else did from software did
and one day I hope that they noticed
that they accidentally included a
Heineken beer can texture within their
trash texture well done from and
congratulations I guess to Heineken for
the free advertising second is something
that very few people understand about
the rat covenant so when you're dragged
into the world of a rat bro you have
huge odds against you you have to deal
with enemy players you have to deal with
traps and you have to deal with 9,000
rats but did you know that you don't
have to kill the enemy player to succeed
in this just run a quick one to around
the enemy player and enter the fog gate
at the end of this stage to emerge
victorious you'll get a ferrous lock
stone and you'll also zone in at the end
of the stage now that you know this you
realize that it's actually kind of a
good thing to get summoned into this
situation because there's no penalty
upon your death and you get the chance
to bypass the entire stage number three
if you play Dark Souls 2 offline you
will have come across Roy a red phantom
with a fetish for invisible gear he's
using an invisible Chatel so be careful
now Roy only shows up when you play in
offline mode and he can drop the items
you see on screen but the true value of
this NPC invasion comes when you're a
part of the champions covenant as you
might know when you kill an invader as a
part of the champions covenant you'll
get an or stone these can be traded in
at the victors stone for the rewards on
screen now these or stones take ages to
get and the biggest reward
actually requires 50 of them and 50
invasions will usually take a few
playthroughs to accrue since NPC red
phantoms don't usually respawn when you
rest at the bonfire but Roy is different
he'll respawn 12 times after resting at
the bonfire just go down and up this
ladder and you trigger his arrival then
kill him rested the bonfire repeat this
12 times then use a bonfire aesthetic to
reset his respawn this is by far the
fastest way to get all the all stones
required for the victors covenant to
play Dark Souls to offline
if you're wondering sign out of your
account on your console or start steam
in offline mode thing you missed number
4 there are red phantoms exclusive to
New Game+ down the pit and they appear
at the bottom of the drop after the
exploding mummies so one of these drops
the dingy set which is exclusive to New
Game+ and it resembles the firekeepers
dingy set from Dark Souls 1 down to the
last detail even the skirt is
blood-stained so does this mean that
this red phantom is anastasiya there are
a lot of links and callbacks to Dark
Souls 1 but this is just one of those
links that really confuses me from a
lore perspective number 5 so we talked
about how from had a Heineken beer can
in one of their textures well they've
done it again look closely in one of
these pillars of trash and you will see
a car wheel I know time is convoluted
but this [ __ ] is too much number 6 now
we get to some of my favorite ones you
know that heartbeat you hear as you
arrive in the gutter when you first
arrive you have to sort of wonder what
it is it really reminded me of the giant
beating heart in Demon Souls in the
Tower of latria but no it's not a heart
it's the statues the statues that shoot
poison appear to have this poison
pulsing through them because when you
destroy the statues around you you
notice that the noise disappears which
is pretty damn cool 7 confused by the
giant passive ant tucked away in the
gutter so was I on my first playthrough
and my second playthrough according to
the guide this species is native to the
land of jugo this ant Queen became an
experiment of Althea's but was discarded
when it outlived its usefulness so what
does it do what purpose does it serve
well you see those fumes it's emitting
they cure poison and you really have to
hand
software for making something that's so
useful in this poison field-level so
goddamn hard to figure out the fumes
also degrade equipment but they do so
extremely slowly berate if you walk
slowly off the cliff near the second
millipede creature
you'll fall onto a Ledge and on this
ledge is a forgotten door three of which
can be found down the pit in majula
accessed by dropping down to a lower
ledge and going up a ladder within this
door is soul vortex some catalysts and
great lightning spear The Forgotten door
in the gutter will lead you to have
Asama which is unfortunately just as
common in Dark Souls 2 PvP as in Dark
Souls 1 PvP and finally inside the
Forgotten door of the Gulch is dark
diver Grand Isle who can be found 3
times throughout the game to unlock a
covenant so where's the key for these
doors well it's down one more ledge from
the one you're on right now
you drop down and you enter this cave
with two elite Giants who I strongly
suggest you take out with ranged attacks
since I'm sure everyone here has been
affected by their ridiculous hitbox they
drop a key they drop a giant soul and
you can also find a ring of giants plus
one down here the next two points are to
do with the rotten so number 9 the
rotten embraces all in the sanctuary for
all things unwanted or tossed away
comprised of hollows there's one in
particular who deserves special
attention the one on his left shoulder
this one dude mimics every action the
rotten makes or maybe he's the one
controlling the rotten mass and number
10 did you know that the rottens arms
can be cut off to reduce his lethality
cut off his right and he'll lose the
butcher's knife cut off his left and he
won't be able to do his smash or his
grab and he'll also drop a ferrous lock
stone the rotten has a few interesting
things going on with him in new game+ he
has the soul of an old dead one which
was nito's soul in Dark Souls 1 this is
a soul that aggregates things together
to become a whole also if you wait
outside his fog gate you can hear him
crying and as you arrive he's trying to
fix one of those statues and lastly the
idea of him dropping a ferrous lock
stone also raises a few more question
so if you want to hear about all the
stories of the things down the pit then
check out this video where I tell those
stories it's actually really interesting
so I hope you enjoy that and I'll catch
you guys next time Cheers